nobody can control how they feel
but you can control what you do with
those feelings
hey there folks this one's going to be a
little bit looser
today but i i'm
in a mood where i i kind of need to talk
about
the way that people get addressed
when they express their feelings about
something and i'm largely gonna filter
this
through um when people
like myself or bipark
um folks or disabled people or
neurodivergent people or any number of
other
underrepresented groups voice
some kind of issue with the piece of
representation that is meant to reflect
them
i i rather frequently see
or hear or have pushed at me
sentiments that basically boil down to
[Music]
you should not be complaining about that
you should just be happy to be present
or you know if you think
that it's bad now what about when you
had nothing
you know this is why people don't want
to represent you because you complain
about everything
basically these statements and these
sentiments
that boil down to
trying to tell other people how to feel
about their own experience
because when we talk about
representation
for any group that we ourselves are a
part of
we're talking about the ways in which we
see our
experience and our lives reflected back
to us
so when you tell someone to not complain
about that or that they shouldn't be
feeling
annoyed about it then you're trying to
tell someone how to feel about their own
life in their own existence
i shouldn't have to tell you that that's
not okay to do
this is as i said gonna be a little bit
loose
i i had thought when i was first
conceptualizing this that i might
you know go and pull clips of the kinds
of things that i'm talking about
but the truth is i'm not gonna do that
because one if you need
help finding examples of anyone who's
going to yell
at minority groups when those groups
talk about representation or a lack of
it
then you are not looking very hard a
b i don't want this to become a call out
channel where i'm citing specific people
and it seems like i'm throwing down a
challenge
and c frankly it's not good for me
i avoid those kinds of channels if i can
for a reason
because it's not good for my own peace
of mind
to indulge in that i deal with it enough
just existing in online spaces being
here
being on twitter being on tick tock
which frankly can be a cesspool
and my own comment sections here if
you're a regular to this channel
you actually don't really see a lot of
the worst parts of the comment section
because i police it diligently and i
have a
lengthy list of flagged
terms phrases and words that will cause
a comment to get
automatically taken out of public view
and set aside for review so that i can
see
oh no it's fine and make it view
publicly viewable or
kill it more often than not if it's
triggered those filters that's what i
have to do
so i'm not going to cite specific
examples of this kind of thing
because i'm living it day to day
and i just need to talk about that
and not um have to show receipts
for the crap that i go through so
it's all the same to you we're gonna
move forward and take it as read
that i'm not making stuff up and if you
think that i am
go away which kind of speaks to the mood
i'm in
i suspect a lot of people i'll do this
as a side note are gonna say something
to the effect of is everything okay did
something happen
no i mean other than just the general
state of the world
and a lot of crap going on especially in
the country that i live in
in a lot of areas but specifically in
regards to
[Music]
black lives matter and they do despite
how many of them
keep getting killed and at the time of
recording we're in the middle of a very
heated trial
around the death of george floyd
and there's stuff like the law that
arkansas passed
and the law that texas is considering in
regards to the
depriving of medical intervention
for transgender youth and in the case of
texas with what they're flirting with
literally criminalizing it
but this is not a place where i'm
prepared or want to unpack any of that
but like
that's the mood i'm in that's that's the
state of the world just kind of put me
at a uh
i'm running out of
state of mind i think most data that
when people have tried to look into this
to any degree and work through the
anonymity of the internet
but even just looking at the context of
the comments i get
these sentiments these mentalities come
primarily from people who are cis
white straight and male
or at least comprise a majority of those
aspects usually
if there's a deviation it's only gonna
be one of those points
there are a few things more infuriating
than people who are not
and have not been for the entirety of my
lifetime and
and theirs as well have never been
shy of representation of themselves
of their life experience in a wide
variety of fashions
telling people who don't see themselves
in media very much if at all
that they should just shut up
and look to a certain degree i do get
part of it
in that i understand that there
is a sentiment among certain creatives
be they writers directors
show runners things like that to
be concerned about trying to do
representation because
they worry that they're gonna do it
wrong and then a hate mob is gonna come
after them
well first of all if you're worried
about doing it wrong then just
put in a little research hiring a
sensitivity reader
is not hard they're not expensive
so getting a set of eyes if you're not
going to have the group that you're
representing in the writers room which
i would argue you should but honestly
it's not an absolute requirement
it's a good idea though bare minimum
just get somebody in
from that group put their eyes on it and
make sure that what you're doing isn't
uh stepping into horrible stereotypes
that maybe you don't even realize are
stereotypes
know what your limits are you don't have
to be afraid
unless you're planning to go it alone
and not consult anybody because unless
you do that
i have a hard time imagining that a
creative is gonna step in it
so bad that they're just gonna get
massive amounts of hate launched at them
i feel like that's the thing so often
they don't
consult anybody
and then they will say well i just won't
do it
then we have less representation and the
kinds of commenters
and vloggers and whatevers
that i'm talking about who then respond
to that and come at people like me
i can cite you the specific example from
a couple years ago
of when i was very upset
at the casting of scarlett johansson in
a role where she was going to play a
trans man ultimately she bowed out of
that the project has since been
reimagined as a tv
show and is moving forward but
i got so much hate being spouted at me
from
again so far as i could tell cis white
straight hetero men
um and like that's not always
supposition oftentimes they drop
very direct hints about that and i'll
get to one of the things they have a
tendency to say
in a minute but coming at me and saying
if you don't let her do this
and allow a cis person to play a trans
person which is
so much horrible baggage short version
is
if you have cis people play trans people
especially if the cis
performer is the gender that the cis
character transitioned out of then it
reinforces the idea that a trans person
is
really their gender assigned at birth
underneath it all and that is wrong and
hurtful and harmful
but they came at me they said you're not
going to get representation at all if
this is the way you're going to behave
basically i got offered up i played a
[ __ ]
i said hey this is bull and was told
eat the bullsh or you won't have
anything to eat at all
no no that's not that's not how this is
gonna work
and i mentioned that like there are
certain things that a lot of these sorts
of commenters will say
in comments to tip that they are cis
straight white hetero men
or at least any number of those things
because one of the common phrases
from people who want to who want folks
like me
or anyone who talks about representation
to shut up
is i don't complain about the
representation
of straight white men like me
of course you don't you don't have to
you don't have to because you have not
lacked for it you are not wanting for it
in both
quantity quality and variety
in all three of those areas you have a
smorgasbord
of choices to find something that will
represent you
whereas people like lgbtq plus and
especially really specific slivers of it
honestly other than gay men
the number of choices that we have to
pick from
in terms of our representation are very
few
and a lot of them have a lot of problems
and if we don't say anything it will
never get better
and more to the point ultimately no
matter what
nobody has a right to tell anybody else
how they should
feel or that if they're angry about
something that they should
be grateful actually
nobody has the right
to tell you how to feel now
if you allow those feelings to turn into
actions that are damaging and harmful
or hateful people can absolutely come at
you for your actions
but not your feelings
if you don't like the fact that i'm
angry over stuff like this or
representation in general
tough if you think i communicate my
anger about that
poorly if you can
tell me that in a way that isn't just
telling me to shut up
i'm prepared to at the very least let
that pass if not engage with it
because you can criticize the way that
i'm going about this but you don't get
to tell me i can't
feel you don't get to say that to me
you don't get to say that to anybody and
you definitely don't get to tell people
who are angry and upset that they should
be
grateful you absolutely
do not and the lack of empathy
is really at the heart of this it is
being
either unable or unwilling
to put yourself into the headspace of
someone else and look
your ability to do that is limited my
ability to do that is limited
anybody's ability to do that is limited
i don't care how
empathetic human being you are there's
only so much you can do to truly
comprehend
the state of mind and the understanding
and the experiences and the feelings of
a completely different human being
there's only so much that you can do
but a total lack of empathy not only
results
in an absolute disregard for the impact
of words that are said to minority
groups
who are trying to talk about things that
are screwed up
but it quickly becomes more insidious
and even conspiratorial
because if you think to yourself
why are they complaining about
representation
i don't complain about representation
and if you are unwilling or unable
to put yourself into the headspace to
establish empathy
with those people then
maybe you start asking what's their
real reason for wanting representation
because you're taking it for granted
that they can't just want it because
they feel underrepresented
because i don't so clearly that's not a
thing
it's a view of life that says only my
perspective is valid
but as i said it can then turn
incredibly insidious because
if you assume that if you assume
my perspective is the perspective
everyone should have i don't feel
underrepresented
there's no way that they would feel
underrepresented or poorly represented
so what are they really up to and this
is part of what is at the heart of every
conspiratorial narrative
in anti-sjw media on this
very f platform
people who are unable to understand why
other human beings
are upset or angry
or disappointed or frustrated
and instead look for a sinister
motivation by what they're doing
because they assume that what they say
is their motivation
just anger at not being represented well
it can't just be that
so what are they really up to and that's
where you get narratives
about how representation is a trojan
horse
to instill and indoctrinate concepts
into children's minds because if you
can't simply express
empathy and understand another human
being's frustration
then the motivations that you come up
with instead
are going to be nonsensical
and often sinister
and this is not purposeful don't mistake
this as a conspiratorial narrative for
me
i'm not saying that people do this on
purpose
they don't they don't sit down and think
oh
what what conspiracy can i weave about
these sjws ooh
maybe some of them do i don't know but
it doesn't matter
i believe in the vast majority of cases
no
they're not doing this on purpose but
they are
refusing to express empathy and come to
understand another human being
and so if you can't understand another
human being on their own terms
you can only see them through the lens
of your terms and you can't understand
the motivation that they claim
then you have to assume that there's a
different motivation
and since you're already assuming that
they're lying then that enables you and
allows you gives you permission
to construct
harmful hurtful
sjw woke liberal
cultural marxism conspiratorial
bull these are rabbit holes
emotional mental thought process
rabbit holes that people fall into
rooted out of a seed
that simply says i don't understand you
and i don't want to
at least not on your terms and
let me also be clear this is not a
mentality a hundred percent restricted
to the anti-woke anti-sjw brigade
i do personally feel it is far more
prevalent
on that side but as i said
i'm not going to construct a conspiracy
narrative about them because i'm telling
them not to construct one about me
because unless you're a billionaire with
the finances to actually influence
public policy
which is screwed up and is the thing
that shouldn't happen but it does and it
is
then no i don't believe if you're just
a commenter if you're a youtuber if
you're
on twitter no
i don't think you have a sinister plan i
just think you refuse to view the world
through the lens
of anyone other than yourself
don't tell people how to feel and when
they tell you how they feel
unless you can give a reason
a tangible substantive reason
to back up the idea that they are not
being honest or genuine
then believe them when they say why
they are upset or why they are saying
the things that they are why they are
angry
if you must take issue with something
take issue
with what they do with that anger and
let's take it one step further if you're
gonna say
okay i understand the problem but you're
going about fixing it the wrong way
you better have an alternative to offer
up
because if you're just gonna tell people
you're being angry the wrong way
and not tell them the right way to do it
then you're just
again that is a more elaborate and
um less direct way of telling them
to shut up don't tell people to shut up
don't do it directly don't do it in a
roundabout
fashion don't do it in my comments
this has been rattling around in my head
almost all day
and i needed to get it out
and maybe it's selfish of me to use this
platform as
a personal therapy inventing thing
this is probably one of the more
tangential
to the remit of this channel sort of
rants that i've done in a long time
sometimes i need it so if you stuck
through it even if you disagree with me
thank you for indulging me whatever your
thoughts are
if you can keep them polite drop them
down in the comments let's talk about it
i have a patreon link in the description
maybe up there probably not
youtube's broken that's one more thing
adding to my frustration as of late
[Music]
but if you are able to support me in any
amount
there is rewards for every tier things
such as being able to vote
on future video topics seeing the docket
in advance
getting to see videos a few days in
advance as well
and there's also youtube memberships
available if you would rather support me
that way you can also get your name of
the credits which you'll be seeing some
of those in a little bit
but you don't have to the usual stuff
like share subscribe
the bell hey why not those help me out
too
but you don't even have to do that
because for all my ranting
and rambling you are the council
and i only run the meetings
until next time this council is
[Music]
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]